Dominique Bernard était professeur de
lettres il aimait les livres et il
aimait les mots à ses élèves il aimait
leur apprendre les mots comme on offre
un présent pour leur construire un
avenir à ses élèves il aimait leur
apprendre les mots car il savait que ce
sont des joyaux de connaissance et de
tolérance vendredi dernier Dominique
Bernard est mort d'enseigné assassiné
par la barbarie du terrorisme
islamiste face à ces tragédies et à leur
répé
les mots peuvent désormais nous sembler
usés et
inutiles pourtant je me refuse d'y
renoncer et je veux donc dire ici et
avec vous aux familles des victimes à
tous les enseignants de France et à tous
les agents de l'éducation nationale je
veux leur dire tout notre soutien et
toute notre
affection on ne prostitue pas impunément
les mots écrivait Albert Camu cette
phrase raisonne aujourd'hui comme un
avertissement à tous ceux qui hurlent
offense quand vous parlez seulement de
liberté d'expression à tous ceux qui
hurlent islamophobie quand vous défendez
simplement la laïcité
elle raisonne comme un avertissement à
ceux qui trahissent les mots par bêtisse
par fanatisme ou par cynisme à ceux pour
qui il est visiblement plus facile de
crier police fasciste que de dire Hamas
terroriste allez-y mon cher
collègue hier soir encore 3 ans après
l'assassinat de son frère Samuel c'est
Michel Patti qui a su trouver les mots
les plus justes je vous remercie de
conclure crime de guerre ou crime contre
l'humanité terrorisme ou décapitation
écoutons madame madame Paty quand elle
nous dit qu'après ces mots-là il n a pas
de en France il y a un point